session will be given by public good
luck on implicit proof systems
you for inviting me for this Workshop
so what I'm going to talk about is not
in the mainstream research in proof
complexity mainstream research is in
Weak proof systems and people are hoping
to prove lower bounds and people are
applying proof systems for understanding
such solvers and so on but if you want
to really understand the problem P
versus the current P versus NP or
proof systems in general then we have to
study also strong systems
strong system naturally appear in
connection with theories which I will
mention in a moment but we would like to
have some commentatorial
characterizations of these strong
systems and therefore it would be good
to start with something that is more
combinatorial
the concept of
implicit true system is something that
essentially can be used it was
introduced by jankraichek
already
almost 20 years ago
and it's a very natural concept so it's
a the idea is that we may have an
exponential size tool but the proof can
be presented succinctly succinctly in
the way that you you have a circuit
which produce bits of the proof and in
this way we have something like a proof
so why why not to consider this
but um
there is an important thing that we have
to realize that we want to get a true
system in in the sense of cook record
which means we should be able to test
whether this exponential large proof is
actually a valid proof so you get a
circuit and now you don't know what the
circuit does so you cannot just
print the whole circuit because it's
exponential large so that there is this
extra condition that
we we also need a
proof that the circuit is uh a concise
version of of the proof in the system p
in this definition uh p is used
for both uh that is for this implicit
exponential potential exponential large
circuit and for proving that this uh
circuit is correct but one can also
study the situation where you use
different things for instance you could
just use one
system like extended frege and then for
for all uh implicit true systems just
increase the the second sorry increase
the first thing and and keep B to B
extended strike that we don't know
whether this would be a weaker concept
so it just shows so this fact that we
don't know just shows how little we know
about about this concept
and there is one problem it's a very
nice definition but but there is one
problem with with this definition
I always think about proof systems not
as a particular algorithm a particular
code that we get
but as a class of
algorithm or all things that are
polynomial equivalent
and now for for this concept of implicit
group system to be uh
reasonable we would like to do the same
but it is not obvious
that if we have to prove system which
polynominally simulate each other then
also the implicit proof system would
simulate each other
a small CNF or is it supposed to provide
duplicity
no we just paid small CNAs the seniors
so this is a very naive question but is
it clear like how the
proof system reasons about the
correctness of the circuit I mean or
what the circuit is like from the proof
System point of view it's good it's much
difficult to imagine what what it does
because uh
typically the proof is uh
consists of a sequence of formulas and
um
you can assume that these formulas are
actually small formulas and then you you
need to prove that the circuit if
a certain part here this formula and
also you have this formula then it they
had to be connected in a particular way
so it's of course something else if you
if the proof system is not based on
formulas
but this is just uh
done by by taking this um
taking care of the computation
and proving the computation
uh actually it's correct because you you
encode the computation
of of the machine they Define the proof
system and you and this group system
indeed to prove that locally it is
correct the consultation it is not
really correct and the the orthod is
what we want and yeah so I could think
of the circuit as maybe like being this
standard setting encoding like your CNF
describing every wire and that's what
the proof system is going to talk about
yes but certainly it's not so easy to
imagine these things and it was going on
and especially if you do one more
iteration
foreign
[Music]
this is something that uh I don't fully
understand it and I want to say say more
about it
I guess your piece of relation you mean
like where you could translate
efficiently the one where it's just the
latest one that would obviously
olderness
but the other one the answer is is yes
that it does carry
the other one that just makes this
more
okay
because how do you know that if if one
proof that's a thing the other proof oh
yeah yeah it's going to be more helpful
if you have a actual algorithm to switch
from one group system to another
so uh
so the the question can be stated uh
so suppose you have a Boolean circuit
that uh
Define some string so the string is
defined by
the output for for all inputs and we we
suppose that we order it
lexicographically or order like the
integers that they represent
and the question is suppose you have a
function computable at polynomial time
does there exist
a function of
such that it would
produce from a circuit
which from from circuit C would produce
the circuit that would
produce the strength of what you obtain
from the string and probably by circuits
is this agreement or what I mean
eventually functions
so
yeah
and then then you get the circuit
and then the circuit produces some
strength
string and the question is can produce a
circuit that would produce the nearest
strength
so what is the answer is it possible
I mean again x equals X for something
yeah but the answer is it's very easy so
consider that this this thing
and obviously if you can do this for for
this function then then you would be
able to test satisfied with it so it's
definite is definable even by a private
automaton not by the employment
construction and still
you you get that you know every time
so
okay so we're
the functions
if it finds one of them
and if it is zero then it
oh right oh okay so
it's taking a string of like a zero one
on the end
so uh so this is a bad name
and now imagine that you you formalize
something by sequent calculus and you
you make a small change so instead of
using uh this rule you would use this
road so that this is completely
equivalent and now now we produce
implicit proof system so are they
polynomial equivalent
considering the previous example then
you are of course not sure that the
airplane
there is also good news I I claim that
for natural formalizations uh you get
polynomial simulations
at least for extended from there
and the reason for this is the the
following theorem that greatly improved
in the in the same paper that
implicit Fragger proof system
is associated with the with the bounded
arithmetic which we denote by B12 it
doesn't matter what it is but the
important thing is that uh for for this
theory that this year improved the
soundness of
implicit
extended fragile
and it also proves that if it proves
soundness of
of some proof system then implicit
extended traded polynomial symbolize p
now what it means is that if you take
some formalization of extended fragrance
such that
you can reproduce credit check proofs
then this formalization for this
formalization you get equivalence of
implicit records so one has to look into
the proof and understand what what is
essential in this proof social that
beings
so I still don't understand this I don't
answer so this is more like an open
[Music]
question
what are natural formalizations but
the possible approach to this question
that I see is to consider
reflection principles
because we know the the following
characterization of
polynomial simulations if we have two
proof systems they suppose the stated
more generally but suppose you have two
proof systems that are strong enough to
prove their own reflection principle
then one group system simulates DB other
if and only if it proves the reflection
principle so we don't have to consider
any any formulas any proof we just need
to focus on this
and if in the reflection principle can
be
represented in some natural and uh
concise way then which would
be able to live to
exponential size then then we would get
this simulation okay so this was just
the introduction to uh this is true
systems
um
and okay so the question is what happens
if if we iterate it
again
yes
so
let me see anyways
thank you so the problem is in the
series so the second or theory about for
a meat screw or the theories which means
that it can argue about sets
and these sets can encode something like
exponential large strings
so so basically the the natural idea is
to unwind this uh succinct succinctly
defined proof into an exponential large
group and argue about this exponential
large group but I I will mention
something similar
foreign
question to to consider a proof system
associated with theories if you have a
first order Theory which is saying
polynomial aximatized then you can
define a very natural proof system
associated with this Theory which is
much stronger than the proof system that
we associate with the with the fragments
of bounded arithmetic
and suppose that this theory is about
natural numbers so so we have equality
but it doesn't matter we just need some
predicated for which it's possible that
it's true or false
so then instead of prepositions
I mean that you can recognize the set of
axioms using polynomial time algorithm
so you can
so they take a professional formula and
substitute uh
the atomic formula
for each proposition an atomic formula
for each proposition and namely for the
ith prepositional variable you take out
freeze out the variable and say that x i
is equal to zero it may be true maybe
maybe not
does you have just a formula that talks
about some variables to be equal to
something and
you can apply logic to prove whether
it's a methodology or not
let me assume the third that we have
some
say trigger formalization on this
so uh
um what do you what do you mean by Trend
replace variable by equation
Atomic formulas which are the equation
of the from x i equals zero
this is
basic proposition in emotional sense
foreign
then uh
uh is the fact that you you can use
quantifiers so if you remember uh there
are this Quantified
propositional calculating in which we
can quantify Boolean
in which we can quantify prepositional
variables but now if you are in first of
all the logic we can quantify uh first
of all the variables so so any any uh
Quantified propositional approves
translates into a proof in this Theory
but uh but this is much stronger
and
even
and the crew system even for for the
really rudimentary part of arithmetic is
extremely stronger it simulates uh
implicit figure and
ideally it's summarize all iteration of
implicit reggae but I would like to
sketch the proof of this theorem very
quickly in the remaining 10 minutes
the first thing is to go from
a business arithmetic to S12
and this is done by interpretation
because you can interpret S12 in queue
and therefore you essentially can use
the power of S12
so from now on let's talk about S12
what Q actually is
the the
zero doesn't have a successor that two
successors of and so on and that X Plus
successor Y is successor of X Plus Y and
for multiplication nothing there is no
interaction
translation
it's
absolutely
they're taking Boolean formulas and
replacing the Boolean propositional
variables using these propositions
[Music]
the best thank you there's no reduction
yes
[Music]
or more efficiently
the first step just to
OK something more
and another thing is that if
but actually to prove something
non-trivial to argue more efficiently
about
esthetologies what we can do we can pass
from from this representation of
statologies by simply using these Atomic
formulas to arithmetic representation
so in here this
fee in a
square brackets means that we we take
the general number of this tautology and
then we Express in arithmetic that it is
a tautology
and then we have some arithmetical
statement which we which we can argue in
some sense more efficiently than if
there's only something like that because
then we can talk about all all things
that are pathologies and and so on so
this is another step
and then
one of the key steps is to show that
S12 proves the soundness of implicit
in the following way that it proves that
every
implicit frigate proof is sound if it is
only of logarithmic length
so formally it means that
X is less than
algorithm y means that the length of X
is
double logarithm of Y
so
or would otherwise we can prove that
that
uh
proof of the implicit and implicit
trigger proof is sound
if we take the gradual number and raised
to to this girl number
which will be something exponential
large then these numbers must still
exist so we know that S12 in general
doesn't prove that for every X there is
this exponentiation so this is indeed
something that that restricts
foreign
and the idea is uh as I said before that
the
proof is small is on the logarithmic
size then you can expand it
which means instead of using uh implicit
definition by a circuit you can really
construct the string
that represent this proof
and then we have a next we have just a
regular extended frigate proof and we
know that there is one to prove uh
sadness for these proofs so so we we can
prove it is sound
okay so what uh
what it what remains is to
show that if we are given a proof then
we have a short proof that there exists
two to the
greater number of this proof
then we will be done
so in in order for a given proof so we
take a proof so this is stated for a
natural number
but uh if you get a proof
then we need to show by construct the
polynomial size group that there exists
to to be
a better number of this proof
and this may seem a like totally obvious
thing if you have a standard number
then
exists in every model not only to the
end everything is in a standard model
but but we have to prove it actually
and it's not completely obvious so let's
let's look
[Music]
uh at how how this is done so uh what
actually is the representation of the
numbers we use the binary representation
using uh
terms of this form which gives us a
logarithmic length representation of the
number
and for for such for such a number we
should show that there exists two to D
the value of this number
but it may seem that you you would
multiply two two two two but you would
have to do it exponentially
Rock time so this this doesn't work
so what uh what uh what I can use is
that the following so this
this uh idea goes back to Sullivan
that one can define a formula
effects
the
defines it's not stated it defines the
initial segment this is not important
but it can be
that is in a sense indicative that
contains zero and with every X it
contains X plus one but also with every
X
and it is Satisfied by 2X
and then moreover uh there exists uh
exponential a large y for every X
once we have this then we we can define
a
once we have this then then we can prove
in
[Music]
polynomial like linearly in many steps
that such a such a term satisfies this
formula
using the first two properties we we
prove in using in many steps that it
satisfies this and once it's satisfied
this we also know that the resistance
and then then we can use
sorry
alpha x is
that means
that's nice
[Music]
yes
you can
for every X Alpha of X is the same thing
yes and the cell property is also not
carrying
property says that the forever X oh
there's this exponential large so so you
would prove that forever there is
yeah
so uh so this is the the whole book uh
let me just put summarize uh so given uh
an implicit very good proof with General
number and
we can construct employment time
and it's logarithmic which is such a
large number and then we use the
soundness for excise proof
this this connection
that the strong system of view
assimilates the
[Applause]
questions
interactive and you see the proof scales
yes
but it's a strong system
of the anti-theory I guess is
well it cannot be completely you must
have a predicate for which you you can
prove that it's understandable because
Center maybe you you also need a
to accept at least two elements
but it's uh the concept is so generous
other fields that are not uh and so on
we take a a simple very low and standard
trigger and look at the implicit
do we get extended Fraga or something
stronger because so it seems like you
should be able to like simulate some of
the Liberals people were talking about
and
yes sure now
um
[Music]
if you take
somebody should help
but you can think just
resolutions
working systems are resolutions
you start with maybe three light
resumptions and then you get already
yeah
foreign
so this is the question
yes I suppose so but
it's like a lot it's quite possible that
you're interested so it's about for
instance if you're scared with reggae
instead of extend this dragon and I
think you get relevant same thing just
you started understanding so there may
be some collapses
[Music]
for example thanks
okay so let's check further questions
offline let's take a bubble again